la frc a le département de la réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la réunion nous
présente terre d'ici
pour
ces sols et son climat en font une
région privilégiée pour la culture des
agrumes
c'est en effet à petit il que philippe
fontaine à implanter ce magnifique
verger sur près de 3 hectares
il cultive ainsi depuis une vingtaine
d'années plusieurs variétés de ses
fruits gorgés de soleil et de vitamines
les voir et il y en a plusieurs
5 g lazib alors qu'on appelle
communément la mandarine après le
deuxième était celle attendue donc c'est
c'est la voie était la production que je
fais plus à ce que les plus prisés après
j'ai essayé aussi dernièrement la voie
était laminé aulas dont rôle un petit
pied juste à côté de nous c'est une
orange croisé avec une mandarine avec
une tante gillot même je dirais elle a
un goût particulier et on peut
l'apprécier comme une orange
brigitte âge déborde bien goûteuse bien
bonne qualité encore marqué par le
passage en début d'année du cyclone
bingiza les arbres ont perdu plus de la
moitié de leurs fruits
et la récolte de cette année s'en
ressent c'est à dire une petite récolte
mais les fruits sont quand même
de bonne qualité gustative mais la peau
ça s'est un peu tâche et parce qu'on
fait de l'agriculture la culture
raisonnée et mais ce qui compte surtout
c'est la qualité du jus et puis la
fraîcheur des fruits
donc là tous les vitamines sont là et je
pense que c'est c'est bon pour la santé
excellent même pour la santé car riche
en vitamine c dans son verger d'agrumes
philippe fontaine cultivant majorité
d'états encore des arbres aujourd'hui
âgé d'une quinzaine d'années est en
pleine production
le temps encore c'est un hybride c'est
un croisement de l'orangé une mandarine
et ont obtenu ce seul foyer de cette
fois mais sa propriété c'est que ce fou
il a été très riche en jus et il a une
bonne qualité de jus il peut bien se
conserver et donc ils sont prisés aussi
par les consommateurs réunionnais pour
obtenir ses fruits magnifique philippe
applique les méthodes de l'agriculture
raisonnée moins de pesticides et plus de
surveillance du verger équipés de la
parcelle d'un piège de mouches à fruits
donc son rôle c'est de capturer les
mouches à fruits et pour les emprisonner
elle est tuée et diminuer la population
de la mouche des fruits
donc depuis que j'ai mis ça cette année
donc ça me ça m'évite les traitements
systématiques en mouche des fruits et ça
nous fait gagner du temps et c'est une
agriculture plus respectueuse de
l'environnement dans les bonnes années
philippe peut ainsi récolter jusqu'à une
centaine de tonnes d'agrumes des tang or
qu'il écoute via sa coopérative et dont
une partie sera transformée en jus de
fruits frais je pense que la
transformation c'est un bon moyen
effectivement pour vendre nos produits
parce que ça va elle permet de déchets
launay l'avant puisqu'on peut conserver
un temps assez court la production est
permis de satisfaire la demande des
clients
il ya des productions saison pas arrivé
à un moment donné tout arrive en même
temps et on arrive à vendre sur le
marché en cause de la surproduction et
la transformation de stockage permet de
réguler un petit peu ce marché
en pleine saison d'agrumes jean-fred
thiancourt livre tous les matins son
précieux chargement de temps mort dans
cette unité de transformation de saint
pierre des fruits bien mûrs et juteux
qui arrive directement d'un verger le
petit il s'est un petit peu abîmés comme
ça c'est un petit peu tâche est vraiment
comment les gens me regardent yeux à
l'oeil pas dire que voilà le fruit les
phares consomme à méo finalement c'est
exactement là il faut consommer s'offrit
forme tous les gens il prend le temps
ben ils connaissent bien le tango c'est
il ya beaucoup de jus dans le temps on
fait le monde du judo tangorre pays bien
près qu'il va falloir tout d'abord
extraire dès leur arrivée les fruits
sont pris en charge immédiatement au
début de la chaîne de conditionnement
ont les réceptions on les perd
après on les trempe pendant cinq minutes
dans un bain et après on les récents
corps dans un autre bain bassin premier
lavage
ensuite un deuxième lavage et ares a
passé avec moi la chine après pressage
opérationnel depuis quelques semaines
seulement
ce tout nouveau pressoir peut ainsi
traiter jusqu'à cinq tonnes de fruits
par jour il en y passent par le plus
rage la centrifugeuse
là bas et maintenant le shifah sport à
pau il revient exactement au fusil donc
là les opérations après le passage
c'est un conditionnement provisoire
avant la mise en bouteille exactement
est donc là on va on va enfin l'euro
mais les fûts en congélation et selon la
tante des cons bientôt là on va
maintenant vous d'ailleurs dans cette
partie de lusine le judo tangorre 100%
pays et mise en bouteille après avoir
été pasteurisé
à l'eau chaude préalablement et
directement et
cette capsule est est refroidi pour
talent évident là
sur cette chaîne de conditionnement
automatisés raymond prunières et ses
collègues s'assure constamment du bon
fonctionnement des machines salage sont
les numéros de l'orage mais le numéro de
lot 130 points 30 et le dé aliot c'est
le 13 12 donné sa parole en chaque
bouteille m'a passé il ya le numéro de
lot de grâce à ce casque protège cette
unité de saint-pierre conditionne ainsi
chaque année 25 millilitres de pur jus
de tango re pays on ajouté
servat turn et
laurent
bien sûr lasseter
plusieurs fruits
de la réunion reste les annales
haléco y aviez les
et
adapté
votre dif 1
de la gamme pré carré
là
la saison d'été
c
fait qu'ils ne subissent
phase de théorisation donc
mc
actif qui est
nutritionnels du produit
quentin
d'autres
oh